this next story really bothers me the
Trump administration has instituted a
new rule that would give homeless
shelters the ability to turn away trans
people trans women and trans trans men
as significantly disturbing when you
consider the number or the percentage of
trans individuals trans people who are
homeless at some point in their lives I
believe the percentage is around one
third one out of three trans people will
be homeless at some point in their life
and the Trump administration has taken
upon itself to give shut homeless
shelters the option previously the Obama
administration took away that ability in
order to protect trans people and this
is what Donald Trump is doing in
response I want to read the actual rule
this is the actual rule that they are
instituting it says quote the proposed
rule permits shelter providers to
consider a range of factors in making
such determinations including privacy
safety practical concerns religious
beliefs and any considerations under
civil rights and non-discrimination
authorities and relevant considerations
rather the individuals sex as reflected
in official government documents as well
as the gender which a person identifies
with the proposed rule does not dictate
a required basis for making
determinations other than they be
consistent with an overall policy so
that last line put is the kicker right
that the hand is pretty bad but the
kicker is the fact that the rules will
not require any basis for making these
determinations just so long as you have
some rules written out so long as you
have a consistent overall policy of
discrimination it's totally okay for you
to discriminate against trans people and
leave them out in the cold homeless
because we have a an unbelievable amount
of homeless people in general but a
unbelievable percentage of trans
individuals who are at some point in
their life homeless but it's cold so
long as you have that policy written
down according to the Trump
administration I want to read some one
response to it
proposal published Wednesday would roll
back Obama era protections to prevent
single sex shelters from discriminating
on the basis of sexual orientation and
gender identity so this particularly
comes into play for shelters that are
single gender here's your thing and how
conservatives will always spend this and
have always spun this they always spend
this as the big bag Big Bad boogeyman
trans woman who sneaks into a bathroom a
woman's bathroom to do something
nefarious and insidious right but they
completely neglect the fact that if you
put a trans woman into an all-male
facility then they themselves are
exposed to tremendous violence and
violation and so they never give any
regard to the life of the individual and
they always create this boogeyman this
this the straw man of an argument to say
that you know if you put a trans person
in a trans woman in a woman's bathroom
or in a woman's facility homeless
shelter then something terrible is going
to happen when we see there is data that
underscores the fact that trans women
are being murdered an unbelievable rate
another quote under the Department of
Housing and Urban Development rule
change homeless shelter operators could
create a policy to consider an
individual's sex for the purposes of
determining accommodation within such
shelters and for the purposes of
determining sex for admission to another
facility any facility or portion thereof
and finally nearly one-third of
transgender Americans who responded to a
2015 survey have experienced
homelessness in their lifetime so this
is a an extremely serious event and a
rule change and what it's going to force
trans individuals to do trans people to
do trans women to have to go in order to
get out of the cold they will have to go
to an all-male facility because their
government documents right they're gonna
go all the way back to the government
documents probably before their sex
change probably for their gender change
and they're going to be forced to live
and to go to shelters based on what's on
that document so it's adding insult to
injury it's it's
it's clearly it's just one of the it's
one of the unnecessarily cruel things
that this administration is doing I've
got stories back-to-back today that
demonstrate the level of cruelness that
this government is operating in for the
most part it is highlighted it's
exacerbated by the Trump administration
but some of it has carried over from the
Obama administration and you'll see that
in the next story but this this story
this story right here is 100% laid at
the feet of Donald Trump and all the
conservative Christian evangelicals who
are obsessed with sexuality obsessed
with their definition of morality their
definition of what is traditional and
and absolutely robbed anyone else of the
opportunity to define what traditional
is for themselves or to define their own
sexual morality or to define their own
sexual identity and they want to compel
the rest of the world the rest of the
nation and the world to live according
to their interpretation of their
religious texts that's what this is
about and as usual the victims in this
are the most marginalized people in our
country across the world it never fails
when an evangelical Christian thing
happens in this country politically the
victims are always some of the most
marginalized people one out of three
transgender Americans will experience
homelessness at some point in their
lifetime and now they have to choose
whether or not to go to a facility that
to a facility with which they don't
identify gender wise or stay out in the
cold
god bless america right if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the David Pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video